you're not always going to be
comfortable to your person's strength
you see that you're going here and
you get in so I mean you're coming for
your attention
by I'm grouping out
okay we're not going here
so I I yields
okay
so in this case when you came in I'm not
going to wait you're not going to
contest here I'm going to go here but
you didn't spinal displaced you see you
get it so that's when I come in and
attack
got it but the first move is you're here
[Music]
but I'm not just getting out of the way
I'm gonna pull you excuse me and that
gives me the opening okay
[Music]
you're wrestling you gotta move up the
Curve
take his energy off
wrong knee try it again right on the
curve though
you're gonna up
it you're gonna up there grab a temp
[Music]
what we're doing today is not getting
stuck on form
pass
[Music]
foreign